du spectacle et de nombreux
rebondissements pour cette première
étape à bois d'arcy la course du soleil
n'en avait que le nom
les 22 équipes cyclistes ont dû
affronter ce dimanche 5 mars les
bourrasques de vent la pluie le
redoutable parcours de 148 km 500
concocté par les organisateurs
dans la vallée de chevreuse et dans le
secteur de plaisir quelques heures avant
le départ les coureurs étaient pourtant
confiant sur le déroulement de la
compétition
moi je suis presque à la maison en plus
on n'est pas loin saint quentin en
yvelines mais j'ai passé des bons
moments à saint quentin sur le vélodrome
c'est beaucoup de motivation mais aussi
un petit peu de pression au départ le
départ justement des milliers de
spectateurs avaient répondu présent pour
pousser les 170 cycliste malgré un temps
pluvieux dans le public de bois d'arcy
des novices mais également des experts
on connais pas tellement les équipes
nous on vient voir juste le spectacle
quoi on est là pour la les voir les
performances
je constate qu y en a quatre qui sont
partis devant le peloton est à bel-air
vachement à l'herbe plus tôt et irait
donc ça veut dire qu'il a dû y avoir
soit des chutes soit plusieurs attaques
c'est surprenant pourra importe corps
aussi facile nommé en tout cas dits
faciles avec peu de difficultés sur le
bitume le sprinteur de la fdj arnaud
démare 25 ans remporte finalement la
course au bout du suspense dans les
derniers mètres en devançant son
compatriote alaphilippe ça a été une
étape absolument magnifique peut-être la
plus belle étape de paris-nice plus
belle première étape de paris nice
depuis 20 ans ou 25 ans avec une bagarre
incroyable avec les conditions
atmosphériques bien sûr qu'ils ont
beaucoup joué
l'appui notamment le vent mais ça a été
quasiment comme une étape de montagne
sauf qu'elle a été remportée par un
sprinteur l'un des meilleurs sprinteurs
du peloton arnaud démare l'ancien
champion de france le vainqueur de milan
san remo l'année dernière un bonheur que
certains ont voulu prolonger en allant à
la rencontre des coureurs après la
course je regarde le matériel je regarde
les coureurs je discute également avec
les personnes
qui sont des passionnés comme moi autour
des camions je regardais mécanicien puis
aussi j'essaye de voir quelques coureurs
qui passe furtivement de du büso à
l'hôtel rendez vous l'année prochaine
dans les yvelines le département
accueillera la course du soleil pendant
au minimum quatre éditions à qui reçoit